it is a humanitarian catastrophe in
mariopol
do you think that nato and the west
should have
acted to prevent
what has happened should it still
act to prevent what could happen there
the whole civilized world should unite
urgently because today we're at the
doorstep of a huge war
you must understand that putin dreams of
capturing more than ukraine
we hear this and we understand this
who knows if he's going to stop at the
borders of our state and he'll not go
and capture poland in the baltic states
you must understand that this is a huge
destructive cruel war which kills tens
of thousands of civilians
our country should be given the chance
today so that we will return to
territories which have been captured by
the enemy and we need weapons for this
we have many strong and courageous men
who can and want to defend our state
but would you like to see nato taking
military action
to stop
the humanitarian catastrophe
i believe that sooner or later this will
happen that we will fight with the enemy
together we must understand that this
war is already happening in ukraine this
big war
and if our allies join in with this war
sooner the sooner we will stop the war
which is now destroying our houses
killing our residents our ukrainians
if we really understand what's happening
now we should unite faster to stop this
enemy so that the enemy will understand
that he will not be able to move further
if that does not happen is mario pole
lost
i believe that mario paul has been and
will remain a ukrainian city and in this
case as i already said we must unite the
whole civilized world must unite for
another purpose and that's to provide
weapons to us which will enable us to
achieve this victory
and the faster they get to ukrainian
armed forces the faster we will be able
to return home
i will go home to mario paul and others
will return to other cities
and we must understand this today we
must take those decisions sooner
one way or another we must understand
there is no other choice it doesn't
exist
we the ukrainians must be given the
possibility to liberate our land
and you
would never accept a
peace agreement
that
gave up
mariopol
there's never been such an issue at the
talks and it will not be raised ever to
surrender mariopol for the sake of peace
we can only return what is ours and
mario paul has been and will remain
ukrainian
and we will do everything to ensure this